[Music]
alright guys the story here I have is
where a 12 postal workers received
medical treatment and dozens more were
evacuated and to the point where there
were six ambulances five first responder
cars and two emergency vehicles that
attended this incident and also three
different fire departments we've all
crises huge drama queens all for a
hundred this suspect body uh what are
the firemen supposed to do I don't know
but what ended up happening was that
they smelled this thing they're just
like this is lethal this is a lethal
odor we must evacuate
remember this is all right I mentioned
this but it's in German I Germany is it
durian Germany oh my god Ivy hilarious
cuz you know it's like a gassy fart it
was like gasoline diarrhea the one Asian
person's like no I know give me somebody
give me a bit is it durian it was during
building it up and I came in and funny
it was dirty in there were four probably
never smelled it in Germany that's why
there are four tide durian fruits which
a 50 year old resident of the town had
their friend sent to them what so they
sent it in a box like a post-office
bottle Oh Jeremy like durian love durian
when I was a kid I was like a treat if I
smelled in the house I'm like oh my god
I'm gonna eat this all day I love you
know I noticed though is it okay maybe
in the States they freeze it and it's
not fresh so it smells worse because
when I had it in Asia I was like oh I
can actually eat did you have it indoors
or outdoors that could be it too when
Nicky but then at the grocery store
still smells when Nicky's making frozen
broccoli
might as well be dirty yeah
or when you open up the first kimchi you
don't like broccoli no frozen broccoli
being cooked is a goddamn nightmare it's
a fart factory wakame don't like thawed
out just like fresh broccoli when we get
those veggie platters it always smells
like who farted in here really I can't
smell broccoli me neither
only when i steam it it smells like
paper I only smell when other people are
cooking it like it's like the frozen one
that you microwave that's the only way
oh oh yeah that's pretty school
if you cook broccoli it's gonna [ __ ]
smoke I like fresh broccoli I never buy
frozen but for even fresh cooks like
[ __ ] really yeah it smells bad I want to
take you to Taiwan oh you're gonna hate
it do I won't prolly I'll just have the
camera on you doesn't prove everyone
wrong about all the cents are
accentuated because of the humid weather
so everything is more potent like even
like car exhaust is just more potent
house it's pretty bad how does it
compare to nine men ranch cuz that
smells pretty bad man that ranch is a
Bri it's wretches [ __ ] Louis Vuitton
shit's [ __ ] Disneyland in there that's
not the childhood but stinky tofu man
that's a that's a whole another game
that's true it's like you'll be like Oh
what is that some baked goods and if I
can hit you in the face and you're like
oh there's [ __ ] why does anyone want to
eat that then they don't smell [ __ ] it
tastes good when you're eating it
doesn't you don't really see all you
like it I don't like hey I got [ __ ] I
got [ __ ] smell pizza it's like
straight-up like how do people figure
this [ __ ] out yeah it will be outside
everything about it is I don't care you
know yeah who ate it you're not supposed
to eat this and so at this point there's
a small ban or does it keep the cut no
you have to open it open I mean it has a
kind of a stench
but not really when you cut it open
you're like what's the smell Kim - if
you had to compare to some gasoline on
diarrhea cuz I love gasoline a buttery
garlic sweet buttery garlic buttery
garlic with sharpie marker you're
selling me those are two things that I
used to get up pour gasoline on the
floor take a [ __ ] on it and take a smell
okay but we did have fresh ones it is
Malaysia and it was pretty good yeah the
fresh ones in Asia um it actually did
have a strong smell and it did have a
bad smell like it didn't smell like [ __ ]
to me
oh we had different species in Asia too
so I think over here I think they only
import like one or whatever but this we
went to this one night market thing and
they were showing like eight different
species almost like like strains of weed
they're like which one do you want this
meat tastes like garlic mango yeah
describe that texture to me it looks
like egg yolks creamy it screaming goes
if the texture is good yeah you like
yogurt with a slight like tofu film I've
only ever tried it once and it was at
your house
Joe and I can't remember foods with you
or one of your roommates
Costard is what sorry what you want a
really good texture though now you know
how to talk to white people prosper
it's a ripe papaya that bean looks like
a dead alien in the middle yeah exactly
look I can't wait to tap into this [ __ ]
your mouth is open like so good I am so
I can handle most smelly things because
growing up in an Asian household you can
see you can't handle that is everything
smells like [ __ ] exactly both the thing
I'm curious about is this thirst rum and
surströmming oh that fish that Michael
made us eat when it was [ __ ] expired
sturgeon no it's that Norwegian I know
so it's a fish and then they ferments it
underground and then they see just even
the can that you buy in stores they
suggest you bring it outside I fill
bucket of water up and then open it up
underwater or else your whole house and
smell I really want to see what that
smell what is it sir surely there when
we ate it from JK party fermented fish
is it the fermented char wasn't bad then
I fire you know ours was bad because the
cameras already exploded and then
Michael's like not so worried about it
so we might try to kill it so we opened
it and then there's bubbles coming out
and then when we tasted it
there's immediately
like biz like from club soda Oh God
and it's Michael like don't worry about
it guys hope you like the fish yeah he
was like oh maybe it's bad then some
speeding yeah the the fish was it was
disintegrating it wasn't even like like
not open underwater terrible maybe we
got a shitty one and you're so [ __ ]
bad-ass I think it depends on what you
grew up eating I feel like you build a
probiotic that is linked to that food
and then I'm jealous cuz I'm a bee okay
well then here's the thing the over time
um I think you get used to it I think I
can probably get used to stinky tofu if
I introduce you eat not though though so
yeah you're cool but it's it's
completely different cuz I grew up with
natto so what's neat oh I smell what you
smell it smells like [ __ ] tasting and
smelling thing I think I've ever tasted
and smelled is the fermented shark from
Iceland oh oh that just sounds gnarly
tastes good at least I liked it and he's
a picky or - are those cube like meet
you they literally serve like the
tiniest portion of it salty taste like
that looks like the chicken I make every
night looks like pork fat no it was like
it was like eating like acid pungent it
was intense why would you do such a
thing
how's Casey ever made this dish at home
are you know Hollow vegetable mm-hmm no
hmm like on tour I think it's like a
vegetable it's hollow and it's kind of
crunchy yeah so I don't need that at
home I don't know because the Cantonese
way to make that there's this other tofu
that you buy us fermented in a jar I
like that one and it's literally like a
corner of it can flavor the whole thing
I was wondering if it tasted like that
and I give is is it that strong it's
like you put one cube in the middle and
20 people can probably eat it what kind
of food is this the Chinese but this
this fermented tofu bean downtown Bao
it's like really really strong and if I
was wondering if the
the fermented shark alarm does Panda
Express have a version oh no no way Jose
people do the same thing too we eat it
with our burgers - tofu bullion that
flavors yeah things and then balut what
the Oh - what's that from what culture
Filipinos look I love helping the food I
ain't do no balut though I like chicken
adobo
give me the Poinsett give me all that
[ __ ] lumpia don't give me this other
stuff I will say cuz we were trying to
eat it for junior party the the juice or
whatever was it did taste good it was
like salty ish but like yummy duck
flavor but I couldn't actually eat the
thing I couldn't I did I don't like duck
bird tastes like [ __ ] you don't like
[ __ ] no I like [ __ ] but I don't like
the one to taste like [ __ ] mmm you
don't like [ __ ] flavored things
no I like only your wife you only want
from your wife first of all yes but I'm
talking about when it tastes like [ __ ]
[ __ ] a vaginal bacteria person yeah
yeah yeah you don't act like that for me
I saw something on tik-tok alaskans like
really remote Alaskans they eat whale
whale blubber
yeah and they cut it like it's still
frozen they cut it and eat it just like
that and I want to try it so unwell so
shoot me in Iceland you just scientists
ate a woolly mammoth that they recovered
from the snow they ate they dig
Department cubed it and [ __ ] ate raw
and they said in today's Vegas girl
figure I mean it's too old yeah what
people taste like all night human being
people did that you should cut parts of
their own self and then they had a
tasting time oh yeah didn't we do that
sounds like a dick he knew he did some
guy had a area severed he was like let's
go eat my feet guy yeah and he created a
whole meal for his friends ah [ __ ] off
to bed Jeffrey yep he's not still alive
because we can ask him I know right we
can tell or someone oh I'm sure no rumor
states really people
the whole coven of his people sacrifice
and eat people is the is the conspiracy
well up top well on how they prepare it
raw sashimi grilled where mind is
amazing know how to prepare it
I would hope a soup I mean meat is meat
but I think that you can get sick from
eating human or like they die I just
watch this thing about a headhunting
tribe where they all have a genetic
disease because they kept you know their
headhunters yeah and then they eat the
he people so they all have a disease and
you could catch your problem people
don't like how nature doesn't want you
to make babies with your own family
members right you're not the police
mhm yeah I don't know I nature something
I want to be I want to eat more like I
want to expand my palate I want to I
want to be challenged because I think
the best way to understand a culture to
is to understand their food and it's
also like their music and all that and
I'm like I don't want to eat the
craziest of the craziest but I I want to
know what they enjoy it's like I'll keep
trying it over and over until I get it
and then I'm like oh this is why they
like it if you want to know what my
culture it's good of any gas station and
then have a honey bun we come from the
same culture corndogs microwavable
corndogs and microwave it for like oh
and it melts the glaze oh it has to be a
cinnamon honey bun Steve called me a
microwave burrito from a gas station
right I was really proud of it yeah no
you are you're the human personification
of such a thing mmm-hmm what's more
American than that yeah always there for
you in the middle right no matter what
because I want to be a burrito you're
one but Gina's a trash like one yeah
well you're like you expect better
El Torito what burrito
I was kidding those breezes always look
incredible but then you bite whining
like oh yeah I don't know if I should be
I like the 7-eleven long green burrito
that's the [ __ ] I don't know what's
Green about it but that's my favorite
one yeah it says it's green that's what
green sauce the tomatillo is that what
it offers in there though
tastes like beam me it says it I guess
there's sauce and I'm supposed to be
there though
[Music]